le syndrome de l'imposteur est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui vous parle on a
toujours l'impression que les autres
savent ce qu'ils font qu' sont au bon
endroit et qu'ils méritent ce qui leur
arrive de positif pourtant nous sommes
nombreus et nombreux à ne pas se sentir
légitime même des personnes aussi
installées que jamis le légendaire
animateur de ses pas sorcier est-ce que
tu as déjà eu le syndrome de l'imposteur
de te dire il me manque un truc qui me
rend légitime à faire ce que je fais ou
ou pas du tout si si je l'ai en
permanence incroyable alors le syndrome
de l'imposteur même si vous connaissez
l'expression est souvent mal compris
c'est un syndrome spécifique et il y a
des solutions je vais vous en parler en
connaissance de cause parce que je
l'éprouve personnellement et plutôt fort
en simultané de cette vidéo mon équipe a
sorti une autre vidéo sur ma chaîne
secondaire ça s'appelle le syndrome de
l'imposteer et c'est une sorte de
documentaire vlog où je leur ai permis
de filmer couper monter comme il voulit
et vous pourrez voir que j'ai pas une
très grosse opinion de mon travail s
tout ça pour vous dire que le sujet me
touche et je crois qu'il fallait faire
une vidéo de référence pour toutes les
personnes qui se reconnaissent
là-dedans alors même s'il y a le mot
syndrome ce n'est pas un trouble c'est
pas une maladie c'est un phénomène
psychologique le phénomène a été décrit
en 1978 par les deux psychologues
Pauline clans et Susanne Himes dans
l'article le phénomène de l'imposteur
chez les femmes hautement performante
dynamique et intervention thérapeutique
dans cette étude elles ont étudié 150
femmes diplômé exerçant des métiers
prestigieux et reconnus pour leurs
compétences or ces femmes brillantes ne
considéraient pas qu'elles avaient
réussi elles expliquaient leur succès
par des FA externe comme le hasard ou la
chance ces femmes pensaient qu'on les
surestimaiit elles craignaient d'être
démasqué et que les autres s'aperçoivent
qu'elles ne sont pas aussi compétentes
qu'ils le croyaient par la suite
d'autres études ont été menées sur ce
phénomène et il a été reconnu que cela
touchait tous les individus de tous les
genre tous les niveaux d'éducation et
tous les domaines
professionnels le syndrome de
l'imposteur qu'on appelle aussi le
syndrome de l'autodidacte est un
phénomène psychologique où une personne
doute constamment de ses compétenence et
de sa réussite et a peur d'être exposé
comme étant un escroc les individus qui
souffrent de ce syndrome ont tendance à
attribuer leur réussite à donc des
facteurs externes la chance le hasard
plutôt qu'à leur propre capacité ils ont
une forte tendance à minimiser leur
succès quitent à s'en dédoiner
totalement comme si ça n'était pas du
tout mais pas du tout grâce à eux si
vous avez vous-même dit ces phrases ou
entendu ces phrases comme j'ai eu de la
chance tout le monde peut le faire bah
c'est rien c'est facile non mais je
m'érite pas ça je suis pas capable alors
vous savez de quoi je vous parle je vous
l'ai dit on l'appelle aussi syndrome de
l'autodidacte parce qu'il touche encore
plus ceux qui ont appris quelque chose
par eux-mêmes je m'explique je me
considère comme un bon percussionniste
alors vous le saviez pas et bien sachez
que durant des années j'ai pris des
cours avec quelqu'un de très compétent
dans ce domaine j'ai travaillé
d'arrachepied selon sa méthode et ses
conseils et je ne doute pas d'être
compétent en tant que
percussionniste c'est pas une belle démo
par contre j'ai appris le mentalisme
tout seul en autodidacte ainsi que le
milieu du spectacle ça a beau faire 12
ans que je suis sur scène je pas très
fier de mon
c'est assez bizarre de vous partager
cette facette de moi mais c'est je crois
le meilleur moyen de vous montrer de
quoi il s'agit l'autodidacte c'est pas
tant celui qui apprend tout seul que
celui dont les connaissances ne sont pas
garanties par un diplôme en toute
logique ce n'est pas parce qu'il n'y a
pas de diplôme qu'il n'y a pas de savoir
ou pas de connaissance quand on est
autodidacte et qu'on nous pose cette
fameuse question quelle étude tu as fait
pour savoir tout ça ou quelle étude tu
as fait pour faire ce métier et que la
réponse est aucune la le syndrome de
l'imposteur se réveille d'autant que
parfois le regard de l'interlocuteur
peut changer soit il est encore plus
impressionné soit il peut être déçu et
remettre en question les connaissance et
le savoir-faire de l'autodidacte le
diplômé peut avoir une assurance tout à
fait légitime j'ai mes diplômes qui
parle pour moi l'autodidacte lui sera en
constante bataille pour prouver sa
valeur aux autres par conséquent ils ont
plus tendance à souffrir de ce sentiment
d'infériorité malgré leur réussite
parfois flagrante le fait de ne pas
avoir suivi un cursus scolaire classique
d'avoir appris par ses propres moyens
une compétence sans accompagnement
accentue énormément l'ancrage qu'on est
peut-être un imposteur le principal
souci de l'autodidacte c'est donc le
manque de légitimité qu'il ressent ou
qu'on lui fait ressentir et rien n'est
fait pour mettre les autodidactes à
l'aise dans une société où le diplôme
prime plus que les compétences avant
d'aborder les quelques points positifs
et les bons conseils il y en a voici
quelques caractéristiques courantes du
syndrome de l'imposteur les doutes
persistants évidemment l'attribution
externe au succès on en a parlé la peur
d'être exposé il y a une crainte
constante d'être découvert comme une
personne incompétente ce qui peut
entraîner une anxiété importante et des
efforts excessifs pour éviter d'être
exposé et en même temps on se dit que si
ça arrive bah c'est bien qu'on avait
raison une comparaison en permanente aux
autres soit pour se rassurer soit pour
se prouver qu'on a raison et qu'on est
un peu imposteur le perfectionnisme
imperfectionnisme excessif est souvent
associé au syndrome de l'imposteur les
individus ont du mal à accepter leurs
erreurs et ont des attentil réalistes de
perfection ceux qui avaient vu l'année
dernière le vlog du projet one shot
savent de quoi je parle pardon
finalement c'est comme si les autres
faisaient une lourde erreur de jugement
à leur égard en disant qu'ils sont bons
les conséquences peuvent aller jusqu'à
apporter son soutien aux idées des
autres et à minimiser ses propres idées
ou ses propres capacités encore une fois
le syndrome de l'imposter n'est ni une
maladie ni un simple manque de confiance
en soi mais comme l'explique Pauline
duckville une perception fausse de la
réalité qui diminue le bien-être et la
quantité de vie des personnes concernées
il ne faut pas confondre le sentiment
d'imposture et un souci d'inclusion le
syndrome d'imposture c'est se dire mes
collègues me pensent plus intelligent
que je ne le suis et non je pense que
les autres doutent que ma place soit ici
ou que je sois assez intelligent pour le
poste c'est pas les autres qui doutent
c'est nous-même entre se croire
incapable et que les autres nous croient
incapables ce sont deux choses très
différentes 70 % des gens auraient déjà
été touché par ce syndrome au moins une
fois dans leur vie estiment les
psychologues dans un domaine ou dans un
autre ce n'est pas un phénomène
universel qui touche tout ce que l'on
fait loin de se limiter au monde du
travail le syndrome de l'imposteur
concerne aussi la vie de famille les
psychologues l'évoquent chez les parents
qui sous-estiment leur aptitude à
s'occuper de leur enfant ou dans le
couple lorsque l'autre renvoie une image
de soi jugé trop valorisante par rapport
à celle qu'on a de nous-même d'après une
étude du journal of behavoral science
pas facile ce syndrome peut-être lié à
diverses causes celle qu'on peut
retrouver durant l'enfance sans rentrer
dans les détails celle à l'âge adulte
souvent dans les périodes de transition
par exemple quand on démarre un nouveau
cursus un nouveau cycle d'étude ou qu'
on obtient une promotion importante et
enfin dans le travail principalement
chez les auto-entrepreneurs et les
travailleurs indépendants dont les
relations professionnelles notamment les
feedback les retours d'information sont
limité ce qui ne leur donne pas toujours
la possibilité d'apprécier leur travail
à leur juste valeur et est-ce que le
syndrome de l'imposteur est une
spécificité féminine il est souvent dit
que les femmes sont plus sujettes à
souffrir du syndrome de l'imposteur mais
toutes les études ne sont pas du tout
d'accord sur ce point d'après une étude
des Assises de la parité datant de 2021
75 % des femmes en sont victimes contre
50 % des hommes une autre étude de 2017
révèle que dès l'âge de 6 ans les filles
pensent qu'elles sont moins
intelligentes les hommes postuleraient à
un emploi s'ils remplissent 60 % des
qualifications demandées tandis qu'une
femme ne postulera que si elle remplit
100 % des qualifications qui lui sont
demandées mais finalement ça peut-être
aussi un simple niveau d'exigence selon
les psychothérapeutes et spécialistes
ellisabeth cadoche et Anne de Montarlot
les femmes seraient davantage sujettes
pour plusieurs raison mais selon
d'autres études récentes les hommes
seraient tout autant concernés que les
femmes selon la psychologue sandyan on
aurait tendance à faire du syndrome une
spécificité féminine car les premières
études ont été menées sur des femmes
pourtant des études ultérieures évoquent
de nombreux cas d'hommes touchés des
étudiants de grands universitaires des
hommes d'affaires des sportifs accomplis
des pirres de famille des artistes et
cetera une étude par contre a révélé que
ce syndrome pouvait avoir des points
positifs le syndrome a le défaut de
générer un stress plus grand les
psychologues yarkis Dotson évoque ce que
l'on appelle la courbe de réaction au
stress qui montre que le stress jusqu'à
un certain point peut améliorer les
performances Bassima tfic a mesuré les
niveaux de syndrome de l'imposteur chez
155 employés d'une société de conseil en
investissement elle a pu grâce à un
questionnaire découvrir quels étaient
les employés qui souffraient du syndrome
de l'imposteur ensuite elle a demandé à
leurs supérieurs d'évaluer les
performances et les compétences
interpersonnelles des employés en leur
demandant dans quelle mesure ils étaient
d'accord avec cette phrase cet employé
créer des relations de travail efficaces
avec ses collègues et d'autres phrases
du même genre l'étude a révélé que les
employés atteints du syndrome de
l'imposteur était généralement jugé
comme ayant de meilleures compétences
interpersonnelles que leur père plus
confiant et était considéré comme tout
aussi compétente dans le travail à
effectuer sachant qu'il y a des
bienfaits et des méfaits il ne faut
peut-être pas forcément chercher à
complètement éradiquer ce sentiment et
ce syndrome en tout cas pas s'il nous
gâche pas la vie complètement conserver
un peu de ce sentiment pourrait
contribuer à un bien-être personnel et
professionnel ça pousse au dépassement
de soi important néanmoins à ce jour
aucune étude n'a montrer que ces
personnes étaient moins
compétentes on va terminer la vidéo avec
quelques conseils pour surmonter ce
syndrome là et puis quelques exemples de
personnes que vous connaissez qui sont
atteints du syndrome de l'imposteur si
vous êtes atteint du syndrome de
l'imposteur vous pouvez utiliser
l'échelle de clans c'est un test mis au
point par la psychologue Pauline clans
qui a découvert ce syndrome ce test
permet d'évaluer l'intensité du syndrome
de l'imposteur tel qu'on le vit on vous
mettra un lien pour ça dans la
description en gros c'est un QCM dont la
plupart des réponses peuvent être pas du
tout vraies rarement parfois souvent
très vrai le deuxième conseil c'est
pensez à votre parcours à votre
situation pensez aux personnes ou aux
événements qui ont pu miner votre
confiance en vous et forcez-vous de
découvrir la source de votre syndrome de
l'imposteur ça c'est important ça
changera pas tout mais vous aurez
conscience d'où ça vient apprenez
également à accepter les éloges dites
simplement merci et pas euh c'est rien
j'ai eu de la chance rechercheer la
critique constructive pour pouvoir
avancer privilégier les relations
positives concentrez-vous sur vos
collègues vos amis et vos mentors qui
sont de votre côté qui voient vos forces
quitent à vous aider avec de la critique
constructive revoyez votre définition de
l'échec être un bon médecin par exemple
ne signifie pas ne jamais faire
d'erreurs même les meilleurs en font les
erreurs sont essentielles pour apprendre
et évoluer évitez de vous comparer
concrètement si vous êtes tenté de vous
comparer à un collègue qui comptabilise
une dizaine d'années d'expérience de
plus que vous et ben abstenez-vous en
revanche faites de cette personne une
source d'inspiration une motivation et
enfin créer un tableau de réussite ça
c'est important pour mieux vous rendre
compte de vos accomplissement faire une
liste de ces victoires personnelles
permet de déjouer les pensées
automatiques du cerveau qui visent à
confirmer notre croyance le fameux
billet de confirmation en se raccrochant
à des faits concrets le factuel c'est
votre meilleur allié plutôt que de se
dire mais non mais moi j'ai jamais rien
fait de bien toute manière j'avance pas
et cetera vous pourrez constater au
contraire que vous avez des réussites
derrière vous je termine en vous citant
quelques personnes célèbres dont vous
vous doutez peut-être pas qu'elles ont
le syndrome de l'imposteer Lena
situation il y a 5 ans Lena après un
séjour de plusieurs mois à New York elle
revient en France et des personnes la
reconnaissent dans la rue lui demandant
des autographes c'est le début de sa
renommée elle a fait une vidéo sur son
syndrome de l'imposture où elle dit
clairement c'est trop pour moi elle
explique qu'elle culpabilise alors
qu'elle sait qu'elle a travaillé mais
elle répète beaucoup je ne mérite pas
tout ça Tomi qui avait déclaré peu
importe ce que l'on fait il y a toujours
un moment qui arrive où on se dit
comment j'en suis arrivé là quand
vont-ils découvrir que je suis en fait
un imposteur et me retirer tout ce que
j'ai vous retrouverez quelques sources
dans la description si vous voulez
creuser plus loin je veux terminer la
vidéo en vous raconant une anecdote de
2011 je faisais mon premier spectacle à
la Comédie des Trois Bornes à Paris
petit théâre de 49 places et au bout de
3 mois j'ai failli tout arrêter et c'est
une amie qui m'a dit ben non il y a du
monde tous les soirs les gens sont
contents pourquoi tu veux arrêter et je
lui avais dit parce qu'à chaque fois que
je sors et que les gens m'attendent pour
me dire ah c'était sympa je me dis
toujours ouf ils se sont pas rendu
compte que c'était nul et encore
aujourd'hui j'ai ce sentiment-là dans la
plupart des choses que je fais dans mon
travail mais on peut le surmonter on
peut aller de l'avant et on peut surtout
rationaliser et essayer d'avoir un
esprit critique sur son travail et de de
quantifier les choses plutôt que d'avoir
ce jugement personnel si vous souffrez
du syndrome de l'imposteur et que c'est
la raison pour laquelle vous avez
regardé la vidéo sachez que c'est pas
complètement irréversible en tout cas
qu'on peut le surmonter et si vous
connaissez simplement des personnes qui
disent toujours non mais je le mérite
pas ou c'est un coup de chance c'est pas
de la fausse modestie elles sont
probablement atteintes de ce petit
phénomène psychologique merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo à très bientôt Ciao